ahora vamos a hablar de salud en directo
américa de france 24 y marina sardiñas
se encuentra conmigo en el estudio
marina bienvenida buena mañana de martes
vamos a hablar de un nuevo estudio
internacional de la revista the lancet
que sugiere que casi la mitad de las
muertes de cáncer en todo el mundo son
atribuibles a factores de riesgo
prevenibles de que se trata de este
informe marina buenos de a raúl pues es
que la la cáncer es la principal causa
de muerte en todo el mundo y si bien
algunas de sus causas pues son
determinantes y conocidas o no son
desconocidos son desconocidas perdón
algunos si tienen nombre y apellidos y
unos factores de riesgos que juegan un
papel muy importante como decía este
nuevo estudio señala que la mitad de las
muertes por cáncer en 2019 a nivel
mundial estos son 445 millones de
decesos se deben a factores de riesgo
evitables como por ejemplo el tabaquismo
o el consumo de alcohol vamos a analizar
un poco cómo se llevó a cabo este
trabajo investigativo que se prolongó
entre los años 2010 y 2019 los
científicos estudiaron concretamente el
impacto del 34 factores de riesgo en las
muertes y la mala salud de 23 tipos de
cáncer encontraron que los factores de
riesgo explica en el 40 y 44 de las
muertes de cáncer y la pérdida del 42 de
los años saludables un hecho que según
la investigación afecta más a los
hombres que a las mujeres puesto que
estos son los que llevan están más
expuestos a estos factores de riesgo lo
que hace que se traduzca en más años
perdidos por la enfermedad discapacidad
o muerte prematura por cáncer para ello
también revisaron los datos de la carga
global de enfermedades lesiones y
factores de riesgo utilizando unos datos
de un proyecto que se denomina divide
por sus siglas en inglés que recopila y
analiza datos globales de muerte y
discapacidad y tomara un entorno de una
muestra de 204 países para estimar la
carga de cáncer atribuible a estos
factores de riesgo conductuales
ambientales ocupacionales y metabólicos
estudiando tanto la mortalidad como los
años de vida ajustados por discapacidad
abbas y qué fue lo que identificaron
bueno rowling identificaron que tanto
las muertes por cáncer atribuibles a
riesgo y en la carga de havat aumentaron
a nivel mundial bueno marina y cuáles
fueron digamos descubrí los factores de
riesgo prevenibles que encontró este
estudio cuáles son además los más
mortíferos si se encontró que los
principales factores de riesgo que
contribuyeron a esta carga global de
cáncer en 2019 fueron conductuales y los
factores de riesgo metabólico se
experimentaron los mayores aumentos de
entre 2019 y 2000 entre 2010 perdón y
2019 estos factores van desde
ambientales como la contaminación la
exposición durante las jornadas la bola
laborales a materiales nocivos como el
amianto que golpea desproporcionalmente
las regiones de china y casi toda europa
también hasta el tabaquismo fumar está
asociado a 16 tipos de cáncer diferentes
el consumo de alcohol tener un índice de
masa corporal alto asociado al sobrepeso
la obesidad o practicar sexo sin
protección o unos niveles elevados de
glucosa en sangre
el estudio señalaba que estos varían en
función de la región geográfica y del
índice socio demográfico también también
en cuanto al género los hombres como
decíamos son más propensos a realizar
estos trabajos que están expuestos a
mayores riesgos
cancerígenos
capacidad atribuible a fumar o el
consumo de alcohol también era más
elevada en el sexo masculino bueno
marina vieja los casos de cáncer no
dejan de aumentar lamentablemente le
pregunto si es la prevención el que vino
a seguir para paliar toda esta
problemática esta crisis de salud están
aumentando y la capacidad de respuesta
no está siendo suficiente en todo el
mismo para controlar esto sólo en 2020
se diagnosticaron más de 19 millones de
nuevos nuevos casos de cáncer en todo el
mundo además también hubo 10 millones de
personas que fallecieron por diferentes
tipos de cáncer y se espera que para
2040 eso aumente a 30 millones de nuevos
casos anuales como los investigadores
señalaban muchos cánceres se pueden
prevenir pero también los gobiernos
deben trabajar en atajar sus políticas y
los factores de riesgo que ya conocemos
y que son potencialmente pues que
potencian nuestros tipos de cáncer no
sólo a través de la prevención primaria
sino también con programas de desarrollo
y para garantizar la capacidad efectiva
de este diagnóstico y tratar a las
personas el cáncer sigue siendo un
importante desafío de la salud pública y
crece a magnitud mundial especialmente
en países del norte global esto fue lo
que dijeron los investigadores
no es casualidad que los comportamientos
asociados con un mayor riesgo de cáncer
que estén modelados de acuerdo con la
pobreza particularmente dentro de los
países la pobreza influye en los
entornos en los que vive la gente y esos
entornos dan forma a las decisiones de
estilo de vida que las personas pueden
tomar la acción para prevenir el cáncer
requiere un esfuerzo concertado dentro y
fuera del sector de la salud esta acción
incluye políticas específicas enfocadas
en reducir la exposición a factores de
riesgo causantes de cáncer como el
consumo de tabaco y de alcohol y el
acceso a vacunas que previenen
infecciones causantes de cáncer
incluidas la hepatitis b y el vph
también como le dicen muchos médicos
marina la mejor medicina es la
preventiva pues no dudar de digamos
detener estas
hábitos sanos con nuestra alimentación
nuestra salud para evitar digamos
cualquier enfermedad y también no dudar
de ir al especialista cuando sintamos
que algo está raro porque también pues
un cáncer atajado a temprana digamos
edad nos existen si se puede decir pues
se tiene uno más posibilidades de vida y
el tratamiento puede ser
más efectivo no marina así es evitar
estos factores de riesgo que conocemos
como decíamos el tabaquismo el
alcoholismo para mejorar nuestra salud y
también para evitar estos tipos de
cáncer que son como dice el estudio el
estudio prevenible gracias.marina como
siempre por toda la información y
pasamos a saludar entonces a nuestro
segundo invitado el día